E aí
o que é que eu tenho essa mania de ficar
me explicando que me enrola e me
complica um pouco de vez em quando é que
de vez em quando eu resolvi me explicar
se eu fico me explicando eu me complico
sem parar é que eu fico atrapalhado
procurando a explicação para explicar
porque eu me explico esse não explico
porque não na verdade se eu me explica o
tanto e sempre fico assim deve ser
alguma coisa que eu não expliquei para
mim ou então eu expliquei mas não
entendi direito porque não expliquei
direito porque ninguém é perfeito mas no
fundo tem um jeito simples de
simplificar só que o simples normalmente
é complicado de explicar é que eu
explico sempre a mais é complicação vem
junto é que eu me explico até demais até
desvio do assunto mas é simples Tem
coisa que não tem explicação ou até tem
mas é melhor não explicar por que é em
vão a investida para tentar descomplicar
o complicado a simplificar o simples e
deixar tudo explicado só complica mais
as coisas e me deixa mais confuso vendo
que na minha cabeça tá sobrando parafuso
é que as peças não se encaixam e por
mais que eu sempre trave sempre tem
alguma solta e eu não em e é por isso
que eu me Explico que é para ver se me
explicando eu acabo me entendendo um
pouquinho de vez em quando mas por mais
que eu me concentre sempre tem alguma
coisa errada porque tudo que eu entendo
é que eu não entendo nada eu só sei que
nada sei' a explicação está dada
Oi boa tarde bom dia né galera eu tô
acostumada acordar de tarde eu já falo
boa tarde
bom dia eu queria pedir um favor para
todos virarem um pouquinho para o lado
de lá alguns segundos olhando assim para
lá por favor
é um pouquinho para o outro lado também
por gentileza aí
e
obrigado é só uma dica que um amigo meu
falou para antes das palestras sempre
conhecer bem o perfil do público
mas na verdade aqui não precisava porque
eu já tô me sentindo em casa na onde só
conheço bem a casa gosto de tá aqui
gosto da nossa parceria e do crescimento
da Universidade que é o crescimento
individual de muita gente também né
então assim Acho que são pessoas que
estão aqui então numa universidade não
porque a família mandou não por que o
papai mandou cortar o curso superior
mais porque tá afim e objetivos e quer
conquistar mais coisas para sua vida
então acho que isso aí já é muito
louvável só por isso para essa
determinação a galera já tá de parabéns
e falando um pouco sobre objetivos eu me
lembro de algumas decisões
que eu tive que tomar
e uma delas foi quando a minha mãe foi
morar em Nova York e eu tinha acabado de
terminar ou Tava terminando o terceiro
ano para gente
olhar escolas lá para mim eu pro meu
irmão para mim seria a universidade para
ele seria uma escola e eu falei que não
iria ela ia trabalhar como jornalista eu
falei que ia ficar porque eu queria
fazer duas coisas eu tinha dois sonhos
um era o jornalismo seguir na
comunicação que eu queria fazer em
português embora já falasse inglês e
gostasse da língua e o outro ela tentar
gravar um disco de rap porque eu tava
fazendo várias letras de rap tem 17 anos
desde os 16 estava fazendo rap sobre
tudo o que acontecia à minha volta e
todos os lugares no ônibus na fila do
alistamento militar em todas as
situações eu virava tudo virada rap E aí
foi uma decisão importante eu fiquei
enquanto ela tava lá as coisas
aconteceram realmente eu fiz uma música
chamada tô feliz o presidente na época
do Collor um pouquinho antes do
impeachment ela foi censurada deu um
Buxixo ou correr atrás de gravadora
tinha outras músicas prontas das coisas
começaram a acontecer na faculdade eu me
atrapalhei um pouco para fazer essa
correria com a música tranquei voltei
tranquei de novo quando fui gravar o
disco e quando as coisas realmente deram
certo eu tive que optar mas foi
contando assim muito rapidamente Foi um
momento de decisão E aí eu me lembro de
uma de uma entrevista que eu vi que eu
recomendo que pesquisem aí na internet
professor e Unos eu só me lembro do
primeiro nome dele é a y u n u n n u s
de Bangladesh é um cara que ganhou o
prêmio Nobel com sistema de microcrédito
e ajudou Muitas comunidades de
Bangladesh e depois ele começou com
outro projeto chamado social Business
que E é só empresas multinacionais que
criam empresas Independentes que não
podem gerar lucro não tem fins
lucrativos mais por exemplo a Danone fez
uma empresa
de iogurte contra a subnutrição e
desnutrição e tal é um cara muito
inteligente inovador mas o que me
interessou e que eu recomendo Foi
simples uma coisa que ele falou e eu me
identifiquei que a como a gente é
educado a pensar pequeno então aquele
objetivo que para nós já é uma vitória
que é
cursar uma universidade sim integrar ao
mercado de trabalho conseguir uma vaga
no emprego pelo já é um motivo de
orgulho mas para ele ele acha que é é
pouco que a gente deve sonhar além da
gente deve pensar porque não a gente
pode se tornar
empregador e não simplesmente se
contentar em ser empregado e a gente
pensar em transformar o mundo em mudar
isso aqui realmente para melhor porque a
gente tem alguns exemplos na humanidade
de pessoas que saíram do nada ou não
importa as suas origens e conseguiram
grandes transformações na cultura na
política e contra as guerras contra
desigualdade tantos exemplos que
poderiam ser um de nós então a gente tem
que seguir o nosso coração Claro seguir
a vontade de fazer sucesso dentro de um
de uma linha né de trabalho mas se me
perguntarem hoje o Gabriel eu faço eu
tenho uma banda como é que faz aí para
fazer sucesso como é que você fez para
fazer sucesso
aí duas coisas uma eu me lembro que eu
não pensava nisso dessa forma eu não
queria ficar famoso eu não queria tirar
onda eu queria falar contra o racismo
contra a ditadura eu lembranças da
ditadura contra a censura
criticar o Playboy agora o que me
incomodar para era muito verdadeiro e
ainda é o que eu faço não é para fazer
sucesso e outra coisa que eu penso é que
se fosse para dar uma dica eu ia falar
para mulher malhar bunda pegar fazer um
botar uns uns peitos o outro pode fazer
assim tem dor assim umas dez frases boas
para ele fazer sucesso e tem as dicas
para fazer sucesso nem parece tão
difícil mas se o cara quiser É realmente
ter uma
realização maior eu acho que ele vai ter
em pequenos e outras coisas que não são
os números do trabalho na sua
multinacional dos discos vendidos eu
aprendi isso na minha área e o nome
dessa palestra Linhas Tortas inspirado
numa música que eu prefiro também que
vocês vejam com calma depois que tem a
ver com isso que eu tô falando sobre o
que eu gosto de fazer que a escrever
cantar
Oi e a vida traz surpresas tempo todo
para gente Linhas Tortas também tem a
ver com isso então ao mesmo tempo em que
eu comecei querendo fazer um disco de
rap não tinha imaginado o tamanho que
isso ia tomar na minha vida o quanto que
eu acabar influenciado tantas pessoas de
várias gerações
histórias lindas que eu escuto de pai e
filho juntos e no cara que largou as
drogas
por mais de um com uma certa música que
a gente fez chamada tem alguém aí de
histórias de superação de
muita coisa bonita mesmo que não dá
tempo de contar
surpreendente e que era muito mais do
que pensar em gravar um disco fazer
sucesso era uma coisa
que veio naturalmente
como outras inesperadas que são o
trabalho que eu faço com futebol o livro
que eu escrevi brincando e também acabou
tendo uma proporção muito grande bonita
também nos lugares onde eu vou as
crianças e os professores trazendo o
feedback que me dá muita alegria muito
orgulho são coisas que que vieram sem
esse planejamento
específico mais o futebol transformando
a vida da Galera por exemplo se você tá
fazendo arquitetura que nos bons cursos
daqui da Unisuam e tá querendo se
enquadrar conseguir um trabalho ganhar o
seu dinheiro tá mas tem um sonho de
voltar naquela cidade de onde você veio
no bairro transformar aquele bairro e
juntar com outras pessoas e tal então
alimento esse sonho e de repente daqui a
dez anos você vai fazer uma outra coisa
muito bonita não tem nada a ver com
aquele sonho mas por linhas tortas você
vai chegar em outras surpresas né aqui é
o poderia falar um pouquinho mais da
minha história dentro de um dos assuntos
que eu costumo falar nas palestras que a
questão do racismo e Preconceito Oi e me
lembro de situações que tem a ver também
com o meu lado de querer transformar de
querer gritar de querer protestar Então
eu fui obrigado a vencer a timidez eu
invadi a palcos para você tentar falar
alguma coisa ou para pedir para cantar
pedia ficava duas horas pedindo para
segurança do evento para cantar chegava
na hora eu quero cortar o meu microfone
várias histórias e teve uma de uma faixa
que a gente pintou contra o racismo eu
convenci quatro amigos e a gente levou a
faixa de 15 metros para o Maracanã no
jogo do Botafogo contra o América se eu
não me engano e eu convencendo Com muito
sacrifício os cara sair e nesse jogo que
eram quase todos os flamenguistas o meu
amigo flamenguista e negro foi mais
assim pela pelo lance do racismo e tinha
um outro que era negro e botafoguense
Que foi o único que se empolgou mesmo
chegamos lá desenrolamos a faixa
a morte ao racismo
e demos a volta no Maracanã inteiro não
tinha aquelas divisórias a gente andou
muito e ninguém aplaudiu ninguém reagiu
ninguém fez nada foi uma frustração
enorme
eu cheguei na grade para colocar a faixa
chegou um cara da torcida organizada do
Botafogo uma moleque que isso aí tá
botando isso aí contra o Ace é o contra
o racismo Cara não sei que a ele a
contra o racismo legal legal é um pouco
Maria lá e me elogiou falou alguma coisa
arruma um cara no Maracanã Gostou da
nossa iniciativa né eu já saí feliz aí
comprei os jornais no dia seguinte para
ver se a foto tinha saiu do em alguma
matéria de esporte naquela curiosidade
mesmo porque eu achava que aquela
iniciativa e a plantar uma sementinha em
quem leis contra o racismo um dia a
gente fez um Eu peguei uma lista de
contatos da minha mãe de jornais
revistas rádios TVs e liguei Olha que o
estudante de comunicação da PUC
a chamar
vocês para cobrir em uma manifestação
manifestação de que é contra o racismo
de quem é Nossa mesmo porque
é porque o racismo é um assunto que a
gente fala muito e tal na época
realmente era as pessoas preferiram não
falar de racismo não tinha lei contra o
racismo não tinha nada dizendo que aqui
não tinha racismo e sempre me deixava
com muita raiva e eu liguei para vários
caras e falei que a manifestação no
pilotis Central Isso Aqui é o alarme
para saber o tempo que eu tinha colocado
aqui ó
já tá quase acabando infelizmente mas eu
te amo
chamado todo mundo aí eu coloquei as
histórias aqui no livro
para lembrar
é porque eu liguei para
e nenhum jornalista apareceu para
conferir nem a minha mãe
Ah mas se fosse até lá encontraria uma
inusitada manifestação de uma pessoa só
e distribuindo um texto para todos os
outros e também para funcionários e
professores sozinho com sua faixa de 15
metros estendida no chão então
distribuir um texto que eu tinha escrito
e
chamado cresça e se esclareça uma coisa
assim panfletária contra o racismo
começava com duas piadas racistas e
perguntava se você achava graça naquilo
você precisava refletir sobre isso isso
isso isso a nossa cultura Nossa mistura
a miscigenação o tal tal tal e pela
primeira vez aí eu falava Vamos acabar
com essa com essas ideias Vamos matar
essas ideias Antes que elas mesmas nos
matem e pela primeira vez eu assinava
assim na vida qualquer coisa Gabriel
contino ou Gabriel o Pensador
é apenas um humilde e jovem rapper que
parou para refletir sobre o seu meio
qual será a sua atitude Obrigado as
moças do xerox pelo uso das máquinas
eu tinha uma loucura de querer mesmo
mobilizar outras pessoas e tal cheguei a
fazer uns panfletos com colagem de
jornal sobre matérias de Buenos Aires e
Paris dos jovens indo para as ruas e uma
matéria sobre corrupção no Brasil e aqui
a gente não faz nada peguei minha
máquina de escrever aqui também tem na
letra lá do Linhas Tortas que a minha
tia avó me deu a máquina de escrever
escrevi e aqui a gente não faz nada não
sei que tá Total se você quiser
participar vamos juntar os jovens um
grupo vamos agir eu não sei o que é se
você quiser participar meu telefone eu
botei meu telefone distribuindo os
prédios da Barra da Tijuca para ver se
alguém me ligava ninguém me ligou
ah
e hoje eu vejo assim com muita
felicidade a galera se unindo eu vi os
protestos do ano passado eu tava
viajando bastante trabalhando eu tava em
Porto Alegre fazendo show no dia de um
protesto gigante lá eu tava em Tangará
da Serra no Mato Grosso
Mato Grosso do Sul Mato Grosso
via as pessoas na cidade bem pequena
falando na minha palestra amanhã vai ter
o protesto a gente vai na prefeitura não
sei que eu vi a coisa muito
abrangente no Brasil claro que ainda
alguma parcialmente né se definindo
durante o processo Quais eram os
objetivos quais eram as reivindicações e
ainda tá assim mas achei bonito achei
uma surpresa muito bem-vinda a à
disposição
dos brasileiros ou é falar dos jovens
mas não foram só os jovens foram os
professores foram pessoas de vários
tipos Had e onde ir para Rua a coragem
de enfrentar a polícia não é fácil a
coragem mesmo de lutar por isso aqui é
uma coisa que eu combate muito na minhas
letras da falando da alienação como eu
citei aqui do Playboy entre outras e
hoje a gente tem não precisa fazer o
panfletinho para pedir para tirar xerox
a gente tem blog tem perfis de Facebook
de tudo e está funcionando tem que
aprender a votar também que seria legal
mas a gente vai ter um processo longo
ainda até plantar até próximo jiren mais
candidatos em que se vale a pena voltar
mas eu lembrei de uma conversa que eu
tive com Marcelo yuka que foi numa
palestra que a gente fez em Curitiba ano
passado é a gente falando no camarim
batendo papo que a gente ficava fazendo
essas letras né de vamos vamos protestar
Até quando você vai levando porrada até
quando vai ficar sem fazer nada
realmente
É mas tinha um pouco a sensação e as
pessoas até botando essa pilha que era
muito ingênua muito ingênua idade da
nossa parte achar que um dia aquelas
pessoas
e aquilo era só para meia dúzia né que o
resto não vai nunca vai acordar nunca
vai acontecer nada tinha um conformismo
uma sensação de impotência em muita
gente quanto mais escândalo a gente ver
E aí continua havendo de
superfaturamento de pessoas morrendo na
fila do hospital de tanta coisa que eu
não preciso dar exemplos aqui tanta
absurdo covardia a gente às vezes acha
que essa m**** não tem jeito né E tem
essa eu tive este momento também e mais
aí o cara colocou isso muito bem que a
gente ia era tido como muito ingênua e
de repente um monte de gente usando
música usando arte usando
câmeras de celulares e o tudo que podia
para realmente trazer de volta essa
esperança de mudar isso aqui isso também
tá sem e
dentro de cada sala de aula dentro de
cada coração de vocês aí de querer
plantar coisas novas de querer colher
coisas novas de construir caminhos
individuais e coletivos eu tenho feito
alguns shows em eventos de formatura e
eu sinto mais ou menos isso que eu tô
sentindo agora Uma emoção boa de
esperança aí é de verdade chega me
emocionar porque vocês vão transformar
vocês vão criar
caminhos novos para os meus filhos para
o Tom e para o Davi que também vão
depois
juntar-se a Esse time aí ou juntar-se ao
time da Unisuam e de outros que estão
por aí chegando para tomar conta não só
do Brasil mas do mundo então eu queria
desejar boa sorte vou encerrar cantando
uma letra tinha algumas outras coisas
que eu gostaria de falar mas foi bom
colocar essa ideia rápido aqui parabéns
a iniciativa e da unison é de fazer a
Ted x educação muito legal é
Gosto de estar envolvido com eventos
como esse e aqui é uma mensagem de força
aí de persistência uma música que quando
eu contei daquelas histórias que as
pessoas trazem para mim eu também
Lembrei de algumas histórias que que tem
a ver com essa letra e uma delas é bem
simbólica para a gente aqui foi um
senhor de cabelo bem branquinho lá no
Rio Grande do Sul que ficou durante a
minha palestra falando assim eu preciso
falar com você o cara falar com você
Você mudou a minha vida eu fiquei
curiosíssimo vai falando falando de amor
de amizade das coisas que eu falo e
acabou a palestra ele veio até o palco
já tinha acabado tudo e a gente foi
trocar as ideia e ele falou Olha você
você eu achei que você fosse bem mais
velho se você é um guri o guri o que a
minha neta me mandou esse texto aqui ó
era o texto da letra que eu vou cantar
agora e ele não sabia nem que era uma
letra nem sabia que eu cantava era assim
um cara que tava
inspirado pela pela letra mesmo pela
pelas palavras ali que a neta mandou
porque ele falou é porque eu sou órfão e
o órgão já traz em si uma insegurança
que é natural então eu decidi voltar a
estudar e eu passei para uma faculdade
é só que na hora eu fraquejei eu
fraquejei eu ia desistir eu ia desistir
com vergonha de não conseguir concluir
com vergonha de tar na na sala de aula
com vergonha com medo porque eu sou
órfão e não sei o que é mas a minha neta
falou que eu não podia desistir e me
mandou esse esse texto aqui você por
e-mail aqui e eu vi que eu falei aquilo
me trouxe uma energia que não sei o quê
e eu vi que eu não tinha o direito de
fraquejar que não sei que ela foi muito
legal assim que ele veio falar e hoje eu
sou mais velho da minha sala não sei que
ela está eu fiquei tão feliz e aqui eu
quero cantar um pouquinho para me
despedir de vocês quero estar junto mais
vezes quero escutar as histórias de
vocês aí acompanhar pela e Diana pela
arapuan as boas histórias as boas-novas
aí do Futuro de vocês também e vai em
frente sem parar que a parada é suicida
Porque a vida é muito curta EA estrada e
comprida você sobe você desce na escada
da vida e às vezes parece que a batalha
está perdida que você voltou para o
ponto de partida vai à luta levanta
revida Vai em frente não se rende não se
prende nesse medo de errar que é errando
que se aprende com o caminho até parece
complicado e às vezes tão difícil que
você se surpreende quando sente de
repente que era tudo muito simples Vai
em frente que você entende boa sorte
firme e forte vá com a força da mente
vai sabendo que não há nenhum peso que
você não aguente Vai Na Marra vai com
garra Vai em frente se agarra no seu
sonho com os residentes para saber o que
é possível é preciso que se tente
conseguir o impossível então tente
sempre alimente a esperança de vencer só
do vídeo de Quem duvida de você sem
parar se parar você cai não repara no
mau tempo que o sol já sai separar sem
parar sem parar você cai bem em frente
enfrente enfrente a vai-vai agora não xô
a ignorar a energia negativa lá fora
porque dentro de você existe um poder
bem maior do que você pensa Vai atrás da
recompensa se houver inveja se houve
ofensa você responde com a Força do
Perdão aumenta a sua crença cada vez que
eu vi um não porque todo não escondiam
Sim ainda só começo vá até o fim aprenda
nos tropeços na olho para o chão olha
para o céu olha para a vida sempre de
cabeça erguida que no fim do túnel tem
uma saída mesmo quando você não consegue
ver a luz fecha os olhos que uma força
te conduz vai em frente vai seguro faz
um furo nesse muro que uma excursão
esclarece Vai em frente simplesmente Vai
em frente que o futuro é um presente que
a vida te oferece
Oi
tudo bom aí obrigado em
E aí